How's it going everyone and welcome back
to another video. In this video, we are
going to talk about relative strength
and weakness. Now, this is a highly
requested video and generally I want to
be longing the stronger asset and
shorting the weaker asset. So, let's get
into the PDF on how I do this. So, now
there are three things that I look for
when determining relative strength or
weakness between correlated assets. The
first will be SMT, the second will be
structure, and the third will be candle
closures. So, let's go over all three of
those. The first one and the easiest is
SMT and that is between correlated
assets a difference in structure. So,
here you can see this is a low and this
is the same low.
We take a look at the same low here and
the same low here. They are making
differences in structure. You can see
this low is a higher low relative to
this low, while this is a lower low
relative to this low.
This is showing that this is a weaker
asset. It is making a new low, while
this is the stronger asset as it is
making a higher low. So, simply put the
one that makes the higher low is the
stronger asset and the one that makes
the lower low is the weaker asset. This
will be the same in the bear scenario,
but just flipped around. So, if I'm
looking to take a long, I want to focus
on the stronger asset or the one making
the higher low and the weaker asset if
I'm shorting or I want to avoid this for
long setups.
The next one is structure and this is
what I use when SMT is not present. So,
taking a look at that same low, the
correlated lows here, you can see we do
not make a difference in structure.
These are both higher lows. So, you can
see this is a higher low relative to
this one. This is a higher low relative
to this one.
So, what is the difference? You want to
take a look at that extreme low and then
the separation between the new low and
that. So, you can see from this higher
low, there is a decent separation
between the previous low. However, on
this asset, there is not much
separation, right? It is quite close
relative to this low, making almost
equal lows. So, when there is not SMT
present, you can take a look at the
separation. The greater the separation,
the stronger the asset. So, you can see
here, this is a stronger asset relative
to this one because it is farther away
from the extreme low.
So, now that you've learned about SMT
and the structure or the separation
between structure, let's take a look at
the third one, which is candle closures.
Now, this is a bit more of an advanced
concept in terms of relative strength
and weakness, but when you're taking a
look at candle closures, they can tell
you which asset is stronger or weaker.
Let's go ahead and start out with candle
two here on the low. You can see we
sweep out the previous low and we close
a nice and bullish. However, on this
weaker asset, we sweep out the low, but
we can't close bullish or back above
candle one's low. This is a pretty solid
sign that this asset on the right is
stronger cuz it is showing that strength
in its candle two closure. Now, as we
continue into candle three, you can see
they are relatively the same there, but
candle four also shows the strength,
right? This is closing as a bullish
candle, while on the weaker asset, this
is a bearish candle.
So, you can see here, if you're just
taking a look at these candle closures,
you can use candle closures alone to
determine relative strength or weakness.
As you can see, this is a stronger asset
in this random candle right here. We
look at that same candle over here and
it shows weakness, right? A doji candle
closing back inside its previous candle,
while this one is closing over. So, when
you pair all three of these things
together, SMT, candle closures, and
structure, that is what I use to
determine relative strength and weakness
through correlated assets. So, let's get
into TradingView and go over a few
examples. So, here we are with our first
example, and before we begin, it is
important that you understand that you
can only do this with correlated assets.
So, for example, here is the S&P 500,
here is the NASDAQ. These are correlated
assets and they should have the same
structure, but sometimes they do not.
So, here you can see if we reference the
same high right here, so the same time
frame high, what do we notice? We go
ahead and mark that out on both assets.
One asset has taken that out while the
other hasn't. So, we can go ahead and
consider that an SMT or a divergence
between the assets as NASDAQ has made a
lower high while the S&P has made a
higher high.
So, by using that, we can determine
which is stronger and which is weaker.
The NASDAQ is weaker as it is making the
lower high. The S&P is stronger as it is
making the higher high. So, that is how
you use SMT to determine relative
strength or weakness. Now, the next one
is separation in candle closures. Let's
see if we can also do that on this
example here. So, let's let this play
forward and see if we can find any
examples of that. So, you can see very
similar structure in terms of candle
closures between these assets here. You
can see weakness in both assets. So,
after we play through that candle, you
notice the S&P has a strong bullish
candle closing over the body, right? A
nice candle to closure. If we notice on
the NASDAQ here, we have more of a doji,
a small range candle. So, what is that
telling us in terms of just candle
closures in strength and weakness It
shows us that the S&P is stronger, the
NASDAQ is weaker.
Let's let this play ahead. You can see
that on this next candle it becomes very
clear. We're not only taking out this
previous candle's low, which we are not
over here, but look at the closure. This
is a doji candle while this is an
engulfing bearish candle. So, combining
those things together, what do we
notice? We notice that we have the
weakness from the SMT.
We're using candle closures to also show
us the weakness, right? And the strength
on this side. Let's also see if we can
use one which is separation.
And we can start to see that here. Let's
take a look at the separation from this
previous high. So, if we're marking out
this previous high on both assets,
how close are we to this high? And if
you notice with the S&P here, we are
relatively close to this high, only a
few points away.
How close are we to that high on Nasdaq,
right? We are quite far away from that
high. So, you can see the separation
between those assets also shows you the
relative strength and weakness. So, when
you combine all three of those things
together, and practice doing that,
you'll really understand the relative
strength and weakness between assets.
So, once again, SMT shows strength or
weakness. We can use candle closures as
well as separation. So, as we let this
play ahead, what do we notice, right? We
notice they both get a drop-off. But,
which drop-off is substantially weaker?
Well, that would be Nasdaq, right? It
has a larger move. And this is just an
anomaly of a day, but it has a great
example of combining all three of those
things that we look for together. Let's
get into another example. So, here we
are in another example, and we have gold
futures on the right here, and then we
have gold GBP on the left here. Let's
take a look at this price action here,
and what do we notice, right? Let's say
we're going into this with a bearish
bias.
So, we can take a look. Take a look at
our current high, and look to the left.
We have taken out this high here. Well,
we have it on this side. So, what is
that? That is an SMT. And what does that
tell us? Is gold or gold GBP weaker?
Gold GBP.
Right? Now, what's another thing we can
look for?
Well, in this case, we don't have
separation from these highs, but you can
look at the separation from the lows,
right? Which is also sometimes just
another SMT. So, if you notice, we are
taking out this low here, while we are
not taking out the low here. So, that
shows that this asset is weaker, while
this one is stronger. So, we don't
really use separation much in this
example here, but let's take a look at
the closures. And this one has a
specific example of where it is
important. So, if you notice, we take a
look, we'll zoom in here.
You can see not much difference in the
closures, but there is one big thing we
notice here. You notice how this candle
closes below,
validating this change in the state of
delivery, while if you take a look at
the same example on the right here, we
can't close below that level. So, what
does that show me? It shows me that
there is weakness in gold GBP, while
gold is a slight bit stronger. Do they
both work out?
And you can see they both continue
lower, but that is a good example of
where not all three will show up, but
one thing I really want you to pay
attention to is a lot of times the
closures, and specifically candles that
create the change in the state of
delivery or continuation, will show you
that relative strength or weakness. So,
another just small example here is if
you take a look at this price action
here.
Right, it's very subtle, but what do we
notice? This candle is closing over its
previous body. This one is not. And it
shows you that this one has the strength
at that time, right, taking out this
high first.
Let's get into another example. So, here
we are in our next example, and we're
going to look at all three things once
again.
SMT, separation, as well as candle
closures. What do we notice here? Do we
have an SMT? Well, we have a couple,
right?
So, you notice we take a look at this
high here. This asset has taken out this
high.
You can see from this high over here, we
have taken out that high
on this right asset.
So, that is one SMT showing strength in
this asset, weakness in this asset, but
we also have another one. And this is
going to show you that there are
multiple SMTs across multiple different
time frames sometimes. So if you take a
look at this high here, right? We take a
look, we've taken it out here.
Where we haven't taken it out here. So
we have multiple SMTs here. Both are
telling us the same thing. This is the
weaker asset. This is the stronger
asset. Now can we use separation here?
Not to the upside, right? We don't
really have it. These are trading
relatively in the same spot on both of
these upside retracements into a fair
value gap here. But what can we notice?
We can notice that we have
what? Taken out this low. And we haven't
taken out this low here, which shows you
what? Weakness in this asset, strength
in this asset.
Does that candle closures tell us much?
No, they're all relatively the same
here. So this would tell us what though?
Where do we want to focus? This asset if
we are bearish, right? So let's see if
we get this continuation lower.
And we do get that trade lower, right?
And you can see they're relatively
moving the same way, but you can also
sometimes use candle closures, right? So
you can see we're getting a little bit
more strength here. Well, let's see what
happens on these next couple candles
here.
Cuz we can use candle closures.
Right? This is where now the strength
has switched a little. Where this is
getting weaker, while this is getting
stronger. How can you tell that? Well,
you can tell by the candle closures.
This is a consolidation. It's kind of
remaining flat, while this one is
getting a bit stronger, right? It's
having more bullish closures.
And so that tells you strength and
weakness is not going to remain
consistent all the time.
Now this one's closer to the lows,
right? So it gets a move towards these
lows quicker, but this one in this area
here I would say is weaker. So let's get
into another example. So here we are in
this next example, and we have a bullish
bias cuz we have a bullish fractal model
here. Now, just using this price action
here, which one is stronger and which
one is weaker focusing on the upside
move?
So, taking a look, there's not really a
very obvious SMT in here, right? You can
see here's this low.
We kind of have the same structure on
the downside here. This is where we can
use separation. And what do I mean by
that? Well, take a look. From this low
here, how close are we to that low or
this low, right? So, take a look at the
structure there. That's the same as this
one here.
And you can see this is quite a bit
further away than this one here. Or you
could even use this low. It doesn't
really matter which low you choose to
look for separation. You can use
multiple, right? You can use all of
those there. So, the separation is
telling us what? This asset here on the
left or gold euro is stronger.
Now, how else could we look at that?
Well, there's a few subtle cues, but
another obvious one would be this one
hasn't taken out the high. This one has.
So, this is the stronger asset. And so,
if you let that play out, let's see if
we can look at some candle closures
here.
Right? And both kind of tell us the same
thing, but once again, subtle things.
This one is sweeping out the high,
closing below, while this one is closing
over the high, closing over its previous
candle. So, this is showing us the
strength in gold euro over gold futures.
So, let's get into another example. So,
here we are in one more example, and
let's combine everything together once
again. So, first, let's look for SMT.
And what do we have? Well, we can take a
look. Here's this low. You notice how we
can't take out this previous low here?
That is SMT. We can find the same low on
this asset here and take a look.
We have SMT on this low.
This one is bullish, right? It is making
a higher low, while this one is making a
lower low. But, that's not the only SMT,
right? We can take a look at this low.
This one is all the way up there, while
this one has ran out its low here.
So, just using SMT, this one is propped
higher. It is stronger. So, I want to be
focused on that one according to SMT.
Let's say for instance, we would use
separation if we had this low and it was
not yet taken out because then it
wouldn't technically be an SMT, right?
Because neither asset has taken it out,
but this one is propped so much lower to
the low than this one.
So, putting that back where it was, what
can we use next? Well, candle closures
as well as SMT. If you notice on the
upside here, we're taking out highs.
That is far more bullish than being
propped lower like that, right? Let's
take a look at candle closures.
We take a look at the same low. They're
both bearish candles, but what do we
notice about the closures here, right?
Let's be specific. This closure can't
close below this down close candle below
this low. This one is closing below
those down close candles, right? So,
that's showing you it's a much weaker
close. Now, let's take a look at the
next candle, right? This candle, yes,
it's bullish. Look at it on this one.
It's bought all the way back up and
closing over this down close candle.
Right, so this one is forming a
continuation,
while this one is not yet reaching for
the opening price of this down close
candle. We can tell that this is a
stronger asset. So, if we want to trade
it, we'd rather focus on trading the
stronger asset and you can see how it's
getting that expansion. Now, let's see
as we let this play forward.
You can see
yes, we take out the high, right? And we
do have a bearish candle here.
This is continuing through the high, and
then this one starts to catch up, right?
But, this is the stronger asset. Now,
just in review, using SMT and then
structure or separation between highs
and lows paired with candle closures on
correlated assets, you can determine the
relative strength and which asset you
should focus on. Now, this shouldn't be
used alone, right? You want to have a
higher time frame framework. You're not
just going to be trading something
because, oh, this one looks more bullish
than the other. You still need a
strategy behind it. But, with that said,
I hope you learned something. If you
enjoyed it, please give it a like and
subscribe, and I'll see you guys next
time. Have a good one.